listening to film courage women
morning I
talk with you
I don't want to be 40 and broke but I
feel like I'm not being true all right I
I don't want to keep telling other
people's stories but no this is good
this is um nuggets here no I I listen to
a lot of interviews myself so I'm just
gonna regurgitate it um but then on the
flip side here's uh here's the the other
argument Vin Diesel when when he was a
young man was a great admirer of
Harrison Ford and and he was working on
some movie that Harrison Ford was in I
don't know if he was an extra or had one
line or what have you but he was on set
with Harrison Ford and he had he just
loved this man so he waits weeks and
weeks and finally finds the right moment
get Harrison Ford alone and says listen
I I have to ask you you have a career
people would kill for how did you do it
and an Harrison Ford takes him aside cuz
I'll tell how I did it I moved to
Hollywood in the 60s with five other
friends we all chipped in money we got
this house and after the first six
months two of them left after the first
year another two left after year and a
half the fifth guy left I never left
leaving was never an option for me and
and that's how I feel about it leaving
is not an option so um you know I'm not
saying if it's not working out give up
move back to your hometown uh because I
don't want to leave and if you're here
to act you shouldn't leave because
acting isn't in Duluth it's here in Los
Angeles or New York